yeah welcome to this video playing
citizen J and Kane going for this always
been only the check Benoni
who do you play this first I don't know
very closed position a term it often
leads to interesting strategical battles
so let's get the night over to g6 Wow
yeah this is so sophisticated
maneuvering to e3 probably yeah why not
can suddenly play that should I am yeah
it's interesting
let's do let's try that
hmm Knight f4 he's playing Knight III
interesting
yeah but if I take now are you yeah he
lets me take interesting check wouldn't
have expected that gets the King to to
e3 or damages the pawn structure
so now g6 f5 cannot really be great to
have the King on e3 okay you will need
to invest a bit of time to repair that
check yep but g7 is not a bad spot
so f4 now right yeah check check
yeah I get the H football
yeah Isis has expelled I said well I
suspected that suspected to that
difficult word for a German Tom so
what's now so certainly nice here maybe
here intending we should default
yeah you should see for a bishop of five
yeah the the bishop on f4 is controlling
eh which is bit a bit annoying so fine
or not
yeah it's probably good anyway
yeah check
soon
King look f8 Bishop deform or something
like that
wait he's maybe tried to play me five
hmm
hmm
changes who probably was was not good
yeah this was a bad move King g7
yeah this is very very shaky now and
completely unnecessary from just a
winning position
are you firefighters going before you
five okay
I can still play five this is ridiculous
I completely forgot about that that he
can can play a five here Ruby seven I
can play King h6 and it continues yeah
this is the silliness
yeah that's it basically the only only
squad to cover g6 check down this is
check this is also coming check Wow
while losing this is really black resign
really terrible after this after giving
the King on f4 haha what bag yeah yeah
this was baby okay it's better for black
head and I don't really need to look for
improvements I mean there there are
maybe is some improvements but it's it's
a clear edge but what I did this is this
is really Betty I need to play rook aged
six now yeah this is a good good one but
it's completely unnecessary what I
should do is and it's not difficult I
just take I need to take seats right
after the king here I never can take
here because of check me but I can take
here now this is this is not going Jack
so it must play here and then just this
and it's it's it's a very very
comfortable position he now never has
this arrived because of Bishop f5 and
this is just better for black with no
particular problem of course and there
was something better than you before but
after after I didn't do that it's it
gets really tricky
the Arouca fate is still good but okay
this is yeah how to how to figure out
can this losers need to take here and
then here
yeah this is still okay right overlook
t5 of course and then my what I did is
similar but I I didn't see that the c5
news was it was coming
check yeah this was sick thanks for
watching anyway